thank you
good evening ladies and gentlemen fellow
councillors
thank you all for coming this evening
[Music]
off on the um uh number one apologies
absolutely
um we've had apologies from cancer
defending uh councillor gavin's
substitute and we've had apologies from
kentucky
thank you um number two minutes from the
previous meetings the first set which
are from monday the 8th of november when
we had the joint meeting at brings with
me are actually just meeting notes as we
were
and then moving on to the next meeting
which was thursday the 25th of november
i'll take these by page
and i'll go by the page number at the
bottom page 9
page 10
page 11.
page 12
page 13.
age 40
and page 15.
i've moved on
thank you councillor
seconded by councillor
please
[Music]
against
any abstentions
public participation do you have any
public participation this evening
item number four takes us on to the
action list
we might take some of these off
personally as well at some point
79
that was for me
extinguished yep
that's i think we can mark that as
complete
um
[Music]
did that go to see now
since christmas
and um is on the forward plan which
we'll go through shortly
um
the joint meeting before matt again is
on forward plan
councillor hodgson um requested that we
write to the fire service which we have
had a response from has everybody seen
this or just me
um it went out in memphis
okay so you can particularly note there
where they have commented in the
response specifically there are no plans
to change the status of apple door fire
station or to reduce the number of fire
engines there
i think that was one of the particular
reasons we felt we wanted to write to
them and we have confirmation
that that's not going to be affected
[Music]
oh that was from
the last meeting which is adrian i think
he's come back to us on that that's done
we've had the most reports
[Music]
and in-house ongoing
when would you like him to
come
i think we'll have to look at the
forward plan we're quite full up
not something i thought what was going
to happen that quickly
um okay
i'll just move on and i'll cover that
point in the in the next bit
[Music]
um declarations of interest members with
interest should refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interest when the item is considered
item number six agreement of agenda
items part one and two we have no part
two
so we're okay there
urgent matters brought forward by the
mission of chair
i don't have any like
checking
and then that brings us on to
um
the chief executive officer which is
vicki rowe is from the um citizens
advice bureau
and because that's um is she still there
all right yes i'm here
there you are can you see me okay
so you can you see us
i can see two people
oh there we go i can see more people now
thank you so first of all can i just
apologize for not being there in
presence this evening and those of you
that know me know that i only live in
appledore so i'm just around the corner
but i
probably is wrongly assumed that the
meeting was on soon tonight so i do
apologize and hopefully um you know i
can still talk to you in the same manner
and of course if any of you want to
check out with me i've got any questions
you can do so um tonight or or after the
meeting if you want to um by emailing me
both stacy and um
sean have my email details so um i
wanted to just do a little sort of
dashboard chat about what citizen's
advice is doing at the moment and how um
how we are
um seeing the impact of the pandemic um
through the people that we help but i
know that you've asked me to come on
specifically tonight to have a chat
about debt and what debt services are
looking like for citizens of ice and
torridge so i'll cover that as well
so hopefully as members you would have
already received our six month impact
report which was sent out in october so
just to summarize that in the first six
months of this financial year we helped
just shy of 1400 people
um with over 3 000 issues
and what we find is that people that
come to us usually have at least two
issues and sometimes they have three
um
and income gains so where we've helped
families to understand or better
understand what they're entitled to
um claim in time in terms of welfare
benefits or it could be local grants and
other other income sources so at the end
of the six month period we were 818 just
shy of 819 000 pounds of income left for
families across torridge
and our projected figures for the end of
this year
will be that we would have supported 3
000
torridge residents with over 7 000
issues
and 1.8 million pounds of income back
into the local
economy so that's the sort of dashboard
data we are still predominantly helping
people
through the telephone and through web
chat email and through facebook
messenger which is
actually becoming very popular
um but we are now helping certain people
with face-to-face appointments um if
they are deemed to be
um
the most deprived in society and can't
access our service in any other in any
other way and our plan is to
continue to increase back the
number of face-to-face appointments and
services that we can offer locally in
torridge but i think just as every other
business
has um adapted to to the pandemic we
realize that there is some merit and
benefit in supporting the majority of
the people that we help
um through the telephone and through web
chat and the other area areas that i've
mentioned
of course if they are able to access and
um
and receive a service in that manner
so currently we're about 90
digital service for for the people that
we help and about 10
face-to-face
and for the face-to-face we're relying
on our own teams understanding
vulnerability but also we're working
with a number of trusted partners
including yourselves at torres district
council to identify
those people that can't possibly access
our service through a digital
manner
so that's how we're currently working as
well
some of you will know
that we have uh we are selling our
premises so we own the premises in
richmond street and we decided
not just on the back of covid we were
already having a premises review but we
just decided that we no longer required
the the premises that we have there at
the top of the high street they're not
particularly accessible
for clients and for staff and not
particularly friendly environments we're
working in and we quite simply in the
new agile way of working no longer
require the space
it was an investment that the charity
um
took in purchasing the the property and
there is some capital to be returned to
the charity so our business plan is very
much now about reducing our costs down
as much as possible to ensure that we're
using the charities money stakeholders
money money at the end of the day
to maximize the
the amount of people that we're helping
and just in terms of that from a digital
perspective because it's much easier to
make to measure
we're helping around 50
of the people that currently need our
help
that's the picture for torridge it's
also the picture of the other follower
sorry the other three local authorities
that we work with so that will be north
devon mid devon and west of them but
it's also the picture for devon and also
the national picture so we've got a long
way to go
to um
you know to better support
against the demand for our services but
every time we increase resource and we
bring new funding in to do that the
demand seems to increase even more so
it's an ever going
a battle i guess
but just in terms of the people we hope
and the support that they need you won't
be at all surprised to to hear
that the majority of the work we do is
around people um having issues or lack
of understanding around welfare benefits
whether that be the universal credit the
new the universal benefit or whether it
be legacy benefits
tax credits
and such so a lot of work still
happening around that 34 of our working
factors around
um benefits issues
we also have a lot of people coming to
us for support with housing
and also debt there are the three main
areas and sometimes and often actually
when people come to us for help they
need support in all three of those areas
they're often interlinked
and the knock-on effect of having issues
in that area of welfare benefits so so
money then
debt and housing we know there's always
a substantial knock-on effect to one's
well-being and people's mental health
so um it's crucial for us to make sure
that our services are delivering and
continue to deliver in those three main
areas
so in total welfare benefits debt and
housing make up about 70 of the work
that we do and what we know particularly
for debt people are people that are
experiencing debt is that they
tend to be the ones that need the
face-to-face support they're less likely
to be able to have their debt issues
sorted and resolved over the phone or by
the other channels that we've mentioned
so for us
the majority of our debt clients will
fall automatically into that
vulnerability
category
so
to talk a little bit more about debt
we currently are funded from two
different funders to deliver debt advice
one of them is
from the dwp the money and pension
service
this is a historical debt provision that
we've
delivered across citizens advice across
the country actually on behalf of the
money and pension service although it's
changed quite considerably over that
time
that contract's due to come to an end
at the end of march
because the money and pension service
went up to tender during this last
financial year and indeed in the
financial year before and the tendering
process has started
so we're unsure as to the certainty of
the money and pension service going
forward
and who will be delivering it but what
we do know is that it is a much reduced
service and very digital
what i can say to you tonight is that
the
recommission process is being somewhat
stalled so we know that citizens advice
will continue to deliver the same
service that it's delivering at the
moment until june
so there's been a slight extension
but we don't know what's happening after
that point
so that's money and pension service and
just to put that into some perspective
we have two paid case workers an
administrator and a team leader so
supervisor technical supervisor working
on that team
we're also funded by henry smith trust
we have a three year funded project to
deliver uh very similar service um to
our to our local people
and that's continuing we're just about
to start the second of three years and
again we have one advisor one debt
advisor
on that team
one supervisor and one administrator
so that's um a concerning position for
us to be in as a charity knowing that we
the evidence is suggesting that we're
going to receive a 60 increase in people
coming to us for debt support over the
next two financial years
a citizens advice nationally is doing
everything they can to work with the
money and pension service around the
continuation of
the service and how where citizens
device fits into that
but um
locally that's very much beyond our
control
so that's uh
that's summary of where we are in terms
of debt and service that we're
delivering
um if anybody wants to ask me any
questions on that or anything else about
the service i'm happy to take them
um vicki can i ask please
can you hear me
i can i i can't see who you are there
i'm afraid but like
my hand up anyway it doesn't matter as
long as you can hear me yeah
i suppose really you're going to see
quite an increase in in people coming to
you asking for advice
um about debt with the energy increases
coming
after april of this year
how how do you see that sort of panning
out clearly
well yeah you're absolutely right so we
have a separate project around energy a
fuel debt and fuel fuel support that's a
project that we run across devon so we
do currently have some resource to
specifically to help people that are
experiencing fuel debt
and we're linked in quite well to the uh
big bigger organizations that might
whose customers may be experiencing pure
debt but um we're by no means going to
be able to meet the demand for for that
and we know that the um energy costs are
going up again they've already gone up
and they're going up again so there is
there is a bit of a concern around how
those people are going to be supported
for those that are able there's quite a
lot of information on our website and of
course people can phone us and they can
web chat and facebook us and they will
get some advice
um
but
in terms of face-to-face advice then
unless they have other
debts then it's unlikely unless they're
deemed vulnerable in their own right
that they will receive
or will be able to get an appointment
any time soon
soon with us but we are working as a
charity across devon with the other
citizens advice and indeed nationally to
try and secure more funding to support
in this area
and as well as
giving advice we also advocate for
change so we record things that aren't
um
we don't believe to be fair in society
and we've got one of the campaigns that
we're looking at at the moment is around
energy
suppliers and and cost of energy and
particularly around pre-paid meters
because that's um often people on
prepaid meetings are paying more than
those on on contract and direct debits
and we're currently working with your
local authority and also devon county
council to distribute the
household um
support funds so the devon county
council one is specifically for people
on prepaid meters that have fuel debt
whereas the your your local authority
and the other local authority pots that
we're working with are slightly more
flexible
so we're working together with your your
teams to make sure that we are
distributing those pots of money but
they're only available as we know until
the end of this financial year
thank you for all your work you do um
you're a league member for torrence that
works with you i don't see you very
often given the cover crisis but
congratulations on all that you do
my question i don't know if you listen
to the money box on saturday there's
lots of issues about the independent uh
individual voluntary arrangements
bankruptcy and options that people take
when they're seriously in debt and there
was a lot of discussion about the poor
provision and advice given by some
agencies that citizens advice were by uh
was given as a place to go to a very
special
advice that they give
um have you had any reactions and any
bad advice advisors with ibas and
bankruptcy petitions
um
yeah we have we are advising on that and
i think it is not useful actually when
we're we're talk when we when you know a
national program says go specifically to
citizens advice for high quality advice
because yes that's what we give but we
don't have the resources to deliver that
to everybody that needs it so um we are
we are
seeing more people
that are
having higher levels of debt and needing
more specialist debt advice um but what
we're also seeing is an increased number
of people that we wouldn't necessarily
expect to have debt problems um
different
clients to those that we may have
expected to see free the pandemic so
what we're hearing and understanding is
a lot of people who have used up credit
or they have delayed payments or they've
shifted or taken advantage of any
financial assistance through the
pandemic
and now as that withdrawals the reality
of their current situation is becoming
clear so people have maxed up on credit
cards had mortgage holidays had personal
loan holidays now having to reschedule
and pay all of those back
so
national citizens of ice have suggested
that we're expecting a 60 increase in um
that in people coming to us
with debt
um on top of what we would have you know
normally usually seen so it is a concern
and you'll know phil from your history
with citizens advice that those
specialist case work cases where with
advising people
at debt really for the level take hours
and hours and hours of work
it's an average of nine hours per
person to get them to that stage and it
can only be done
would usually only be done via
face-to-face we have the ability and the
qualifications and the staff to do it
but it's limited resources limited
thank you
can i ask a second question chair
i'll depart oh and then i'll go to
cancer langton thank you yeah i just
wanted if you could comment or think
about the inequality between working age
people and pensioner people um
interestingly the all fuel prices will
affect both working agent pensioner
but
pensioners don't pay national insurance
contributions and from the first of
april working-age people have to pay
national insurance contributions to
cover the care grant that's going to be
now put in place
is there any policy or any comment from
citizens advice about this what appears
to be an inequality between working age
and pension age people given the age um
profile of torridge
actually do you know that's a really
good question and one that i will take
back so it's not something that national
citizens advise have
asked us as a local citizens device to
start looking at but it's certainly a
campaign that we could look at locally
across torridge and potentially across
our other three local areas so it's not
something that we've advised on or
certainly not something that's come to
my attention which means we haven't
advised
significantly on it but certainly it's
something i could have a look at and see
whether there's anything that we can do
to push for some change if we believe
that there is an equality there
thank you thank you thank you chair
thank you council
thank you um thank you can i just that
come back to something you said earlier
i may have misunderstood did you say
that you're only able to help 50 of the
people
that um that come to you is is that
because you just haven't got the
resources to anyone else or because
you're just not successful with the
other 50 i didn't quite understand
yes sorry yeah no absolutely sorry
council i didn't catch your name but
yes so we are
only able to meet 50 of the demand
currently
trying to get through to our service
from a digital perspective so that would
be by the telephone web chat email or
facebook messenger it's much harder for
us to understand the current
face-to-face demand because we're not
open nine to five like we used to be
um
and also a lot of people have got used
to working in different ways so it's to
do with two things one is funding so we
can only deliver on what we have funding
to do and the second is around
resourcing
particularly volunteers so before the
pandemic we had 150 volunteers of which
38 i believe nearly 40 of them were
torridge
volunteers
we now have 17
so we have to recruit and we're
recruiting we were recruiting through
both pandemic years 2020 and 2021
and we have been successful in
recruiting but we haven't recruited back
up to the number that we need in order
for us to better meet demand but as i
alluded to at the beginning of the
session
even
regardless of recruitment of volunteers
the demand is increasing
uh i think we we're looking at 11
increase this
for the first six months this year in
torridge in comparison to last year and
that's only set to go up so it's a
constant battle for us
to bring new funding in as well as
retaining existing forms of funding and
to keep our resource
resources as high as we can and the
dynamics of volunteering have changed uh
they were changing anyway but i think
they changed dramatically on the back of
the coverage pandemic we are less likely
to attract
volunteers into the service which is a
real issue and business priority for us
to work out
how we're going to work around that
because
for every one volunteer that's you know
a day of paid resource that we don't
have to find funding for
so yes you were right 50
is currently
the demand that we're hitting
so
can can i just ask then what then
what then happens to the other 50 do you
do you know
what where they go
so some of them will find alternative
services if there are any local services
and if the doors are open for them for
them to do that
or if they're able to access digitally
some will self help through our website
i mean we can see people that are
self-help through our website um
obviously we don't know what support
what what
links they've clicked on and whether or
not they've taken the advice that
they've read then um but we know that
there's there's quite a few significant
increase in people that are accessing
our website and the national website but
the honest answer to that is that some
will drop through the net some won't be
helped
and some will be trying to reach other
services that are still available
but they're all reducing whether they're
statutory or
or third sector
thank you thank you thank you so vicky
what would you say um the average person
how long do they have to wait before
they can um receive advice whether it's
digitally
or you know what's the average somebody
has to wait
yes so if it's by the telephone or
through web chat then it tends to be
within the first week of them making
contact for those that for those that
reach us
we will respond to them initially and
then they should get advice within the
first week but for a face-to-face
appointment the current wait time is
four weeks
unless it's a priority
and by that we mean
that someone's being threatened with
homelessness about the bailiffs at the
door in which case we do have some
emergency appointment slots
okay thank you anyone else got any that
they'd like to ask vicky or
anything they'd like to add
absolutely not normally that's quiet
don't encourage me i'm enjoying being
educated thanks chad
is there any other topics that think he
might be able to
other than debt that you're interested
in the citizens advice offer
so you're saying then vicky that debt
hands-in and welfare benefits are kind
of like your top three that are coming
in the door at the moment
or contacting you
yeah
yeah absolutely i mean it's always been
the case for us
to be fair that you know that tends to
always be the way it is but i mean
through
through the pandemic we did also see an
increase in uh
problems uh particularly domestic
violence which again is no surprise
um but that seems to have settled a
little bit in terms of people coming to
us for advice but yeah main area of
concern going forward is with debt given
the expected increase in demand and also
the uncertainty about the money and
pension service
going forward
is there anything else that came to you
for like advice or anything that's
different or unusual throughout the
pandemic
um no not really i mean we
we wouldn't necessarily have that data
unless there was something that you as a
council wanted to look at in which case
if there was we can see if anyone's come
to us i mean the way that we look at the
data from a dashboard perspective is we
look at the main areas and then
everything else is clustered into other
so that sort of 30 is you know more
clustered into into other but if there
was an area that you were concerned
about as a council that you wanted to
see if people were coming to us about uh
you know about that certain concern that
you had then we can we can have a look a
little bit more at the data to see if
anybody is um accessing our services for
that reason
and one other thing i wanted to ask was
about the contact free facebook
messenger
um if somebody is that like a local
torridge page or is it citizen's advice
across the floor that you support or
yeah so
that's the message you just say yeah
yeah so so yeah no that's a good
question so the messenger is ours it's
local to us at torridge north mid and
west devon it's manned by
um actually paid staff
in the organization so we have a
generated auto generated message if
someone messages us to say give us a bit
more detail and we'll get back to you
and also it covers the consent and then
we're able to to get back to people it's
actually one of the quickest access
routes into the service at the moment so
if um if any of you know of anyone that
needs to get advice from us and they can
use social media it's the quickest way
to get through to us
um just just in
from that though the web chat is
national
so all local citizens devices um
participate in web chat but to access
web chat
uh somebody would need to go onto the
national website let's say they would
search for debt and then the web chat
option would pop up so in terms of web
chat we're helping people from all over
the country and people from all over the
country are helping our local people as
well
but the telephone
is also just ours so we were in a
different group telephone services but
it wasn't working for us so we've come
out and we're just
going it alone so i mean the percentage
really was i know i've tried to use the
services with other people before we've
gone into a national
rather than just the devon wide
yeah so so now it will just be torridge
north mid and west devon
and if nobody's available to answer it
there is a national overflow
um but
if we can answer it we will answer it
and it makes it will make um actually
we're hoping that it makes uh
an ink we're hoping we're able to help
more people this way by managing our own
voters and peak times because before
when we were in a group with devon we
were less able to do that against our
local demand
now we can see very clearly the peak
trends for demand
for telephone call service and we can
manage our results accordingly
i'm good i'm glad that's working well
anybody else
got any more if they see there can be
simple questions like that i have a
question
mr bart please vicky can i ask you also
about um
obviously we know about debts and
relationships and those sort of things
but about neighborly disputes we see an
awful lot of television programs now
where neighbors are you know having
battles with one another do you find
that's on the increase
yes
we haven't i haven't got data for you on
it but it's actually something we were
having a discussion about just last week
uh within our organization
yes it is and i i think it's probably
down to the fact that people are
spending or have spent more time at home
so but yes we are seeing that and we do
link in with local services local um
mediation services so that
people can
get access to to mediation which is the
normal route for
neighborhood
problems but yeah we do we've always had
a flurry of it to be fair
um
it's quite an interesting advice area
but we are seeing an increase on it
presumably you work quite closely with
the council anyway you were talking
earlier about um
linking with the council but
is there anything that you would
ask the council could do for you
what would you want from us
well
other than the obvious which i always
ask for which is more money of which
none of you have we understand that um
we've been working very closely with
sean and also with stacey about making
sure that um the people that need our
advice and support get it and vice versa
that the people that come to us
understand what's available to them
through torridge district council so i
think that's a relationship that we've
tried to build on particularly
operationally to make sure that that's
happening um and also trying to bridge
those gaps so for those really
vulnerable people
where are they going in the town you
know whether that be a bit of a
torrential where are they going and when
our doors aren't open because none of
our doors are open like they were before
and trying to really understand where
the vulnerability is and not just with
torridge but with other partner
organizations that are working in
torridge as well so that we can be
better joined up
so that there are less people falling
through
the gaps
but more funding would be lovely of
course
and then she's just stole my sign-up
question
oh sorry
anybody else
you're all very quiet tonight
that's the leather
well i will speak if you want me to okay
thanks vicky for that i'm i'm a big
supporter of citizens at cab anyway
and i'm also
being on tourism on northern town
council i always post when the grant
period comes in
to give a good grant to the cab
and this afternoon i printed off
actually i've got it in front of me
our impact in 2021 that you
that's on your website and the case
study i was really amazed at
was a client that you were able to help
who had real problems with
the idea of
a child with learning just difficulties
but the upshot of it and of course they
had 20 grand taking off their universal
credit when that was taken back
and they were really and then some debt
but
looking down through the case study that
the work you were able to do for them
resulted i thought it was incredible
in the annual uplift for that family of
10
459 plans a year
which i think is fantastic
and the client described the help that
they perceived as a lifesaver and i'm
sure it was a lifesaver and i think for
me that is
the real
benefit for me of the cab is
where you can
get more money in from various sources
for people in the district
and in the area that you can cover that
for me is what i always stress when
counselors are discussing
ue support to this level this year a bit
more
that it's for the pound that
we pay you get an awful lot back within
what you do
and i notice you said the volunteers
have dropped off at the minute but what
about your paid staff and they still
holding
and thank you for asking so yeah we've
managed to retain all of our pay staff
and indeed
through some funding that we were able
to to get our hands on on on around the
code bid we've managed to uh covered
impact we've managed to recruit a few
more people as well so yes all staff are
well thank you and we are a growing
organization we have a plan to to grow
our income well we had had a plan to
grow our income which was slightly
stalled by the pandemic but we still
have a plan to grow our income we know
we need to do more to help more people
to get closer to demand so
we are um looking at avenues and
different
ways of income generating i guess and
going back to that question around you
know what can we do together
very often
local authorities have insight into
funding opportunities that we could
potentially partly partner on with you
so i'd be really interested in taking
those conversations forward with stacy
what can we do to support you and the
work that you're doing because it over
overlaps doesn't it
so um yes so we need to find increased
areas of funding to support those people
and there are opportunities out there
for funding
but often it's the strength of the the
partnership that
that needs to deal but you're absolutely
writing what you say about the work we
do when people are able to get incorrect
to us when they reach the service then
we have some amazing
outcomes um for families not you know
financial and well-being wise that make
a huge difference to their lives um the
problem that we have is is um
is meeting that demand is being able to
get more people to actually
be able to reach the service
yeah
and i think just um touching on the
volunteers
um know when i worked in the
volunteering sector it was becoming
harder and harder to recruit and find
volunteers because the retirement age is
increasing
um people aren't getting as much money
so a lot of people are still working
part-time and most people don't have
that spare time to dispose of them to go
and volunteer
so i think looking at you know
where a lot of volunteers do come from
which is the
retired sector that sector is just
getting smaller and smaller
because the entire retirement age is
increasing and you haven't got as much
spare time and i think when you do get
to retire you think that's it
i am retiring
so you know i understand what you say
about volunteers it's it's ever
increasingly
different and difficult to find a pocket
of where they are
um i think councillor newton's got a
question for you now vicky
so just following on from what you were
saying there chad
we
we heard reported within the last couple
of days nationally that
the um
job vacancies nationally are are
increasing even more as we know and one
of the reasons that we we were given or
we were certainly being carried on the
news
was that a lot of people
have retired
taken early retirement because of the
the the pandemic and the change of
lifestyle that that forced upon them um
so
perhaps that
the argument you are making their chair
maybe
um for a period of time may be slightly
offset because the suggestion is that
actually
quite a number of people um
who weren't quite at retiring age but
were probably close to have actually
come out of the the um
the workforce group at the moment but
interesting
my other point um and i haven't got my
mates to hand
are we directly granting to
the do we know how much we're giving you
as a direct grant um per year at the
moment
yes so yes you do
grant us directly um i don't have the
entire
actual figure
to my mind but it's
either 32 or 38 000 pounds to remember
that we work with four local authorities
so i have all of the information on the
top of my head but it's either 32 or 38
000 pounds
um so yes you do you do give us that
that grant apparently and i understand
from sean and of our conversations with
sean and stacy that that will continue
for the next financial year which we're
very grateful
for
um and yes i take your point about
retirement i would question how many of
those are in torridge i think it's more
likely to be people retiring um
but hopefully they might move down here
you never know and um
and come and volunteer with us but
you're right we mustn't just assume that
that's the case that people are working
longer but what we're finding is that
people have are making different
lifestyle choices um whether it be
caring for grandchildren or simply
simply retiring and enjoying enjoying
their retirement
thank you
just to come back if i may chat on on
the question of the grant and that's why
i i came in on that um
wearing a different hat of the ons uh
internal committee where we look at the
budget and scrutinize the
the grand giving um
ask for more
um
we are tight for money of course we are
but um
[Music]
if you don't ask you absolutely won't
get more um and you have a compelling
case uh and and also you know you are
providing huge value for money so um
do ask for more doesn't mean you'll
necessarily get it but um uh if you're
there asking we actually know to look at
you and consider you so i would
encourage you to ask them
that's um that's useful to hear so we
you know i mean i know stacy's in the
meeting tonight isn't she so we had a
conversation with sean and stacy about
that and um sean felt that it would be
difficult for us to
expect anything more than what we were
currently receiving due to the um
you know to budget restraints and such
but if there is any opportunity to
reopen that conversation we will
absolutely do that and i'll take that
forward with stacey
[Music]
um and just to point out vicki as well
i'm sure you do know that um each
individual counsellor does get a grant
pot of money to
disperse across their community so
i don't know whether it's worth you
sometimes asking the individuals for the
extra odd bit of money
people struggle to shift their money
which seems crazy but it does happen i
know some people aren't approached
um
i know where to give mine out all the
time i could deal with more
but um
you know it can be worth asking if
anybody has got anything they've got
left that they wish to
grant towards you as well on top of the
yeah that's a very good point thank you
i'll do that thanks
yes
that's what i said
um anybody else
i was just wondering where the face
points take place um if the premises
being solved
i couldn't hear that i'm so sorry i
couldn't hear the question
i was just wondering where the
face-to-face appointments take place you
said that the premises is being sold
yeah thank you i did mean to cover that
actually so thank you for reminding me
so at the moment we're still at the top
of bridgeton street we're having a
conversation with the medical center on
the top of uh on the corner of abdiction
road they've got some space there so
it's likely but not agreed yet that we
will be moving our face-to-face service
up there but we also are open to options
and want to be as flexible and agile as
possible so you know in this current
era that we're living in we can take an
advisor and a laptop and we can pretty
much give advice from wherever so we're
quite happy to be flexible we're looking
at what's happening in the town
what other partners what other
organizations there are in the town or
the towns within torridge and seeing how
we can best
start to meet that that face-to-face
demand so
um we've been restricted as everyone is
and getting that going we thought we
were getting going a few months ago and
of course then the restrictions sort of
came back in again so as the
restrictions lift we'll do more and more
face to face and we'll have more
conversations about what that looks like
in the town
but certainly we'll have a base it looks
very promising that we will have a solid
base up at the medical center
okay thank you i think a similar
organization has just moved out aren't
they
yeah i'm not i think the the space that
we may be occupying was um
the the school but if a college had it
before i understand
okay
yeah
they've moved that the off-site center
to on-site
now so i think it's there
okay
anybody else
well i think that looks like it vicky
thank you very much for
attending tonight
virtual or not virtual i think it's
worked really well actually
um
i don't know if you've got any questions
for us
other than for more money
no well no i haven't other than to say
as i did at the beginning that um
we do in our impact reporting we give
sort of dashboard summary overview of
data if there's anything more specific
that you want we can provide that for
you as members in your local
wards and communities if there's an area
that you're particularly interested in
and we are as we said working closely
operationally with your teams anyway
about managing and supporting the people
that need the service in the community
and will carry on doing that but if
there's anything that you're working on
as a
group that you want some data or some
detail on we're happy to support where
we can
lovely thank you for taking the time to
meet with us tonight vicky
um i'm gonna have your tea
yeah thank you
okay nice to speak to you all i'm sorry
i wasn't there in person
okay bye now take care bye bye
[Music]
she's off yes uh can i make a
proposition that
we ask or suggest to cnr
um that they consider an uplift of the
grant that we give to citizens advice
to some of 50 000 pounds in this next
year rather than 32 or 30.
um specifically
justified by the
um
the increased work that is heading their
way especially with the the energy price
increase um which is being very well
articulated
would you like to kind of
ring fence that money particularly the
debt or
i can go into their general budget
oh no i'm not going to tell you where
you come i
i thought you might help actually if i
just explained some of the background
and the funding that we do have
currently and why you've been working
with the cab it might not change your
proposal but i'm not sure if members are
aware so um the government gave out five
million pounds to devon
some of that's come straight to torrance
and some of that's gone directly to the
cab
um specifically for things like heating
costs to catch up on bills so the reason
we're working heavily with the cav at
the moment is because they've got
funding for people
who have gas or electric on a key meter
so they can give money out on top of
their key to keep them warm this winter
and then we've got access to other funds
called the household support fund uh
where we can assist people who aren't on
key meetings i mean we can assist people
that are on key meetings but i see if
they've already got that funding
so um we were given
80 000 pounds
um october november time we've spent
that uh alongside the cab
and i'm working with encompass and we've
just been given another 50 000 pounds
again to go towards hardship schemes and
people in fuel property i think
indications out the room they haven't
promised but when that runs out there
should be another sum of money coming
forward as well so the same for the cab
so just saying numbers are aware there
are there is quite a lot of funding
around at the moment for people who have
it
thanks stacey
my understanding traditionally the
greatest help and benefit that the
citizens advice provide
is advice
and facilitating people to be able to
either
um
unscramble that their debt situation or
whatever or consolidate that or whatever
it is rather than straight handouts of
money
my and our our grant historically will
be i suspect more around
assisting the local citizens base with
their infrastructure and and and
employing people to to to actually give
that advice out
and i would have
thought that an increase in our budget
uh specifically to help to try to give
them more capacity um by by allowing
them to or help employ extra people or
whatever
because it's there that you're really
going to grow that capacity because it's
the advice that comes out so i
chair you mentioned ring fencing uh i i
would
perhaps the suggestion is that yes it is
specifically
uh
to assist with their infrastructure
is
space to do their pop-up shops as well
so they can have people in the office or
maybe have some because
what they're saying is they're like just
said a minute ago they could go anywhere
with a laptop and i know they're looking
for permanent premises but what we've
said is look we're quite happy to
accommodate that so if you want
a property
you know even temporary for a day
um we could probably accommodate that
for you as well
um the other point that you just raised
is absolutely right with regard to the
handouts that was part of the problem
because you're just sticking and
sticking past her over a problem and
that's why we've teamed up with cab and
encompass and moving on to what council
11 was saying earlier there's a lot of
people out there that aren't claiming
all of they're entitled to so they need
that specific um benefit advice
and even things such as the bedroom
taxes people
um that shouldn't necessarily pay that
they've got a medical condition so
that's what this has been able to
achieve kind of working together
with not just that the money gets them
out of the hole and gets them stable for
a bit but it's that long-term um debt
advice money management advice um you
know to try and
put them in a better position for the
future
[Music]
um
[Music]
okay then so
to
put counsellor
newton's proposal in a nutshell it's to
increase our current funding from 32 or
38
up until 50 in the next financial year
and
councillor little hunk in the second
flat so i'm going to take that to the
boat now all those in favor
okay
[Music]
okay i think that sums that up
next we need to go on to the um
consideration
[Music]
i struggle with it it's on a3 both sides
and then so
[Music]
when she gets a couple hours
to make it a bit more
easy to read so okay we're on cycle six
which is tonight
and going forward
um the joint meeting with north devon
um
north devon have received an invite and
it's been circulated to their members um
health are going to send some people
which will be our next meeting which is
actually going to be february the 9th
that was going to be march karen that's
going to they can do february
[Music]
um so we haven't got anything in for the
march meeting
which is going to be the february one
but we're going to keep the march one
there
in case we decide once we've gone
through this that we need an additional
meeting
so we've got the health meeting lined up
and the people that we've got come in
um they're aware of what we want
and few chances from memphis
do you want to talk to me
um sorry if i just put you on the spot
no that's fine
so i know you've been talking to them
yes so i think the um the request from
members was to cover commissioning and
um
dental and dental i'd and that's
something i will take away actually so i
don't think i've raised that but sue
mitchell who works in the communications
team at the trust has said that
the um specific question that members
are asking
and the people who are attending um will
be able to cover that um so i think the
names of the people were listed
they're essentially one is the deputy
chief executive
devon
and then
there's
our future hospital we've got the
program director of our future hospital
program and then we've got the director
of strategy
and then we've got the deputy chief
executive officer and then the
communications and engagement officer so
it's going to be quite well attended
uh by soon yeah okay coming by zoom yeah
it's not coming but pretty soon yeah um
so a north devon indicating that they
wish to join us so we contacted north
devon council and um
they've sent out an invite to members we
as yet i haven't heard back to um
from anybody saying that they're gonna
be attending
um but i do think they um did meet with
um the um health trust about our future
hospitals so
um
previously so in october time i think so
it may be that members feel like they've
already come talk to everyone feel like
they've already had well if it doesn't
become a joint meeting then i think
we'll just have it ourselves i think
it's an important meeting that we need
to have
and we also need to hear what they've
heard
so um
that's for february
march
and then
for um april we're looking at another
joint meeting
and so far we've got the chief executive
from northern has requested some more
specifics what this is going to be about
we've got anybody
lined up
we haven't done so much work on this one
have we yet um no so we haven't got
anybody um invited from southwest water
or the environment agency um north devon
when we contacted them about setting up
a joint meeting
um
some of their counsellors have also
raised questions around um sewage
and
local rivers and seas but um
they want some more detail around
exactly what the meeting
aims to cover and i guess outcomes and
that kind of like depends on who will
get in
what it's going to cover
so i think we'll do some work together
and see who we're going to get it's not
till april obviously which everyone's a
bit more pressing and if we've got
nothing for the march one which we might
have in a minute
um
you know we can always miss that one and
then this takes me on to
i hope you've all had a chance to read i
found it quite lengthy um the letter
from big devon
which is um looking at
a different type of fuel biomass
anaerobic digester plants
[Music]
they're they're wanting to come in
i'm not really sure what they're asking
for
well they wanted i thought they wanted a
or
representatives from our council were we
interested in joining
them and others
cycle when this first came through it
was about planning
issues was that another letter
i can't remember
that i'd have to go back through
and that's why it kind of took me a bit
by surprise
when it was um
it links to planning because it mentions
it should this inquiry take place or
this body be put together to look at
this
one of the things they want to look at
is
is how uh is that planners should take
account of
the movement of this
or when they agree to setting up
um these
um things these biomass things whatever
that they then seem to increase in size
and before you know it there's stuff
being shipped all over the county or
something and the planners should be
aware of this that was my understanding
when i but i'm not sure that we sort of
have this jurisdiction the right word
because planning policy is set not by us
is it
or am i wrong
well my understanding when i read it was
that if if this happens one of the
things they might decide to do
if planning policy is in such a position
that it can't be changed the pressure
should be put on the policy makers to
change the policy that
having read it that's what i thought it
was
absolutely
uh can i suggest actually the target for
this uh
maybe more the review into the local
plan which is going on
together with north dakota
because through the local plan
one may be able to
um
exert some influence
other than that you're absolutely right
it's national guidelines that drive it
any concerns about anaerobic digesters
is through the local plan
if
the two authorities want to make some
condition
affecting
their presence within the era um or or
considerations that that should be taken
into a account
do you know what i'm gonna do
i think i've just i'm gonna um and i
should have done it before but with
christmas and everything it's just been
so busy i'm going to put in a phone call
and see exactly what they're asking us
to do and what they want us to do
and then
put that down
for me
because i've read it but it's just heavy
reading as well i think basically i mean
that's fine yeah
but i mean i think basically they want
to find out if anyone from our council
would
would support you know
and set on the inquiry that's what came
through in the original first letter
um
i'll put in a phone call
i mean it's not going to go anywhere
fast is it so if it goes on to the next
meeting
um and then
we've got the uh letter from natural
devon
and they are asking to come in and
present to us
um which of course they're welcome to do
and it would be good because these are
actually asking for financial assistance
it doesn't say how much and it doesn't
say particularly what for
um
so it's you know it's kind of up to you
guys it's not just me
his centaurus district council suggested
they would like to pledge towards his
work earlier in the year
well i think this do we know if we did
this one's gone around a bit
because they are actually asking for
funds and they are an external
organization
so they may have had that conversation
with somebody else because i
don't recollect
what's in my time not in your time
either karen
no
um chair it came through from um
via an email trail so
and it was decided i think by the chief
executive bringing it to external for
that reason because it's funding related
[Music]
and i've spoken to them and said that
we're fully booked into june and they're
happy to
attend so do we do we want to complement
the june
[Music]
and i think we should get them in and
obviously scrutinize them because
sorry okay so
that's us kind of like pull up until
june now
um we'll get together and do some more
work on the april meeting obviously
we've concentrated on february 1.
anybody else have anything they'd like
to say about the forward plan or that
they'd like to so will they not be
winning marching okay
okay
anyone got any questions
um
i i actually
i don't know much about it and i i'm not
an expert and i think they're probably
people on the council if you are i but
having
read it i think it probably would be a
good thing to support what they say
is i wonder whether it's a bit more for
i feel he may have a burning
ambition too
i'll have a chat with them
let's let's see what they say if we
think it should go to climate then
that's where we can put it can't i
yeah
good
okay all right